why do we tell stories
why stories are so important in our
lives why we crave him so much
what makes a great story why stories
affect us
how do you tell a great story how we
tell stories
who we tell stories to and for what is
your story
what should i write is this a story that
that i should tell
that i'm able to tell or i'm interested
in telling what stories to tell
and what not to tell what to keep out
can you tell the story
what do you want to write about like
what's your idea is this the actual
right idea for the story is this the
right story to tell based on that idea
what turns you on about that idea what
type of writing
really excited you are you writing what
you like to write or are you writing
what you like to watch
does this hit me on a gut level after
months of
doing this what am i still responding to
what am i still interested in what
interests you what will
again what will sustain you why do you
want to tell the story
why am i telling this story why are you
the person to tell this story
why this story why now why you
why i would want to tell this story
thinking about why this would be
important or how i can make it
important on some level or make it
personal to me how is this my story how
is
whatever the story is how does it relate
to me so that i can use my emotions
to go to tell this story better can you
tell it
honestly am i challenging myself
and so if i'm not challenged or if i'm
not surprised
or if i'm not in a new place by the end
of the writing
that i was at the start then i haven't
done my own job to myself
what is my point of view um in trying to
tell a story
um what am i trying to get at that's
different
what's going to make my voice different
what can you write
what's the only the story that only you
can write the stories that you can write
or the themes that only you can write
what can you create
that isn't something that's just an
imitation of what others are doing but
that's unique to you
that no one else could have created that
you create something fresh in the world
that's truthful and meaningful
is this fresh is this original is this
authentic to your
to the story you're trying to tell what
is your world
view what has happened to you in your
life
that has caused you pain
and given you something to say and
how does your writing reflect that
how to get out there in the world how to
get out of there for many reasons they
have to figure out how to get out of
their home and out of their comfort zone
what experiences can i have that are
going to later inform my writing
and that's a fun way to live what's your
deepest most personal embarrassing
secret
if you had no fear if there was no fear
what story would you tell if i was
guaranteed success
absolutely guarantee success doing
anything as a writer
what would i be doing and if you look
inside and you feel like the energy
maybe isn't there you need to ask
yourself is that a story
i really want to tell if it's not fun
you're writing
it's not fun why are you writing it but
the question is are you then going to be
honest with yourself and say i don't
like writing this so then you'll stop
writing that and start
writing what you do like reminding
yourself of why you
started this to begin with if you start
there the audience is going what
happened
the end is off in the beginning i often
write backwards i often think of an
ending
and then i think what's a fun way to get
there how does it end
like what is the ending i need to know
where this is going and then i figure
how do we get there
how does a writer know where the
beginning is where to start the story
what's the look what's the hook you know
that central conceit
where do you see this going where i'm
going what genre is this story
what's the genre a true identity and
what genre it is
what if we did this as a drama wait a
minute what if we did this as a thriller
what if you spun it this way what's the
premise here what's your narrative
question driving the story
what are the things that one really
needs in a story idea how universal
is it seeing something in the world and
thinking about how it makes me feel
and then oftentimes hypothesizing from
that or extrapolating from that
into a sort of genre story how are
people going to relate to this
can anybody find something in this
relationship i'm creating
in this conflict that i'm creating that
they recognize something how can we keep
this grounded you know how can we keep
this story believable
what's it going to be about what the
hell is this movie going to be about
what's the heart and soul of this
what's the theme and what's your theme
what's your thematic question
their theme about what they want to say
what is it that we're trying to say and
how are we saying it and are we really
affecting
not only good story but are we really
saying something with the way that we're
going
what are you trying to say with this
what is the themes what is it you the
director the writers the actors
what do you want to say what do you want
to say with this story
and where there's the plot line there's
a theme line so the plot line answers
the question
what is the story about the theme line
answers the question what does the story
mean
how is this a story that everyone and
every time and every place
could sign on to what is the story what
is the movie story or what is the tv
story what is this what is this thing
that's happening what is this big event
and what are we watching for sort of the
bulk of the movie
and then i just start to think about
what the movie might look like
in my head what do we see and what do we
hear we don't really talk about
imagination
like what that is and like how we like
what if what if that whole thing it's
one thing to have a great idea
but i think how you get into that idea
that's a huge part of it what a
situation is and what a story is
do you know how to listen to a story do
you know how to hear a story
is this big enough to be a movie to me
that's what the story is what's the
central problem here it's like what was
that about
well it was about whether the person
would get this well just number page one
to a hundred and i'm like what happens
on every this is every minute of the
movie this is every page what happens on
every
and every minute of this movie what
happens next what's the beginning of the
story what's the end of act one
what's the end of act two and what's the
ending of the story
do i actually have a beginning middle
and end and do i have a story
what actually happens in this movie from
a b to c like how does it start what is
the middle what is the end
you start to think about the overall
story
the act breakdowns uh when things are
going to happen
where they need to happen how did it get
from this to that
all of these little details about how we
actually get from a to c
are the things that people don't think
about until they're on the page and then
they're
then they're stuck and they stop what's
the problem with the center of the story
does this problem sound really
compelling and entertaining to watch
is an audience going to care about this
problem that this main character or
these characters are trying to solve
can you come up with a puzzle can you
come up with some
interesting image
or some line of dialogue or something
that
is puzzling it leaves a gap in our
understanding
and makes us wonder what might be around
the corner that could be the thing that
you know
that explains something is something
that anyone can watch and be like i
don't know what i would do in that
situation
i want to see how this person is going
to do it why are we following this
character what did
that moment have to do with that moment
what am i trying to say and why have i
selected
this character to take the journey with
why this character
why is this woman the protagonist who
the characters are what the log line is
how what the pitch is
what's the situation and what character
can be tested the most in that situation
what is the effect of this plot on this
character that's what we actually care
about
i think it starts with uh how you define
what a hero is even
what's the heroic journey of this
character how do you see this character
usually the hero of the story are you
writing characters that you know
very well or are you writing characters
that you observe
for me it's like i like to create the
characters put them in a scenario and
see where they go
whose story is told how is it told
who are the heroes and shiros who are
the villains knowing who your characters
are
knowing who's going to go on this
journey figuring out why we should care
about them
who the protagonist is what their
journey is through the story what
transformation
they're going through who are they what
are they about who are these characters
really like what do they want
if you just met this person for five
minutes at the grocery store
never seen them before what would your
first couple takeaways be do i know can
i feel can i
sense do i have any idea of what's
really going on inside these characters
who's your protagonist what's their goal
what is their visible goal that they're
going after
what they want and what they need what
does the central character want
if i don't know that the story doesn't
work
what does the main character want and
what are they trying to avoid
what does the character want uh why now
and what happens if they don't get it
you know so it's asking those three
questions which form a kind of litmus
test to whether the scene is worth it
how does the personal
of the central character linked to the
professional
pursuit and really being
clear on
if there's a link and very often there
isn't a link what's the nature of the
problem or what's the nature of the goal
for the main character
am i following the journey of this
character are they taking action for the
goal
do they think it's going to move them
closer to their goal
or at least overcome an obstacle to
achieving their goal
are they reacting to what happens to
them
if the protagonist isn't compelling
if we don't have a an emotional
connection to them
then what's the point right what a
character is
who she wants to be versus who she is
define what she
does tell us what does she do and
that'll tell us who she is
who your character is by action what is
he doing that tells the audience
who they or he or she what are they
doing that tells the audience who they
are
i want to know what the character's
physically doing like what am i watching
them do what was his intention how you
know what was his plan did he have a
plan
is he going on just all of these things
that are going on inside the character
does anybody in your story actually make
a positive change in their personality
i think there should always be some
element of sacrifice
and remember that the word sacrifice
means
to make sacred how is this character
going to change
in the course of this story what's the
character's arc what do they have to
learn how
what kind of courage do they have to
show because if you can identify
that in my mind you've identified what
the movie's about identify
your main three characters what is their
path
and then do you want them to stay there
do you want them to grow into the next
level
or are they going to be taken down to a
lower level
and then try to struggle their way back
up or maybe they're switching
from one path to another that's a lot of
dramatic conflict there maybe you've got
someone on the warrior path
who wants to give that up and go be a
poet get on the
lover path and so what are the the
conflicts there
that arise from them shifting their arc
path
who they are and what that relationship
is who needs to come into that
character's life
to help help them on this journey help
them accomplish this mission and what is
that relationship like
is there a connection is there a clear
want which leads to the dramatic
question which is will
this protagonist successfully save the
love of his
life whatever whatever that whole of
identity of who am i
who loves me who do i love back and
where do i belong
what little things can you do to to
make a character stick out in someone's
mind why is the character this way and
what is the character love more than
anything in the world
and why is that and what do they fear
more than anything in the world and why
is that
how to get that character to believe in
the truth that's already beating in
their heart
what makes them a compelling relatable
person
even before the main story problem has
kicked in what makes us just kind of
want to follow them where are they when
the movie starts
are they in a happy place are they in a
sad place did they just break up with a
boyfriend
are they on top of the world did they
just get fired
is there a pivotal thing that happened
that damaged them
what state of mind emotional mental
spiritual physical whatever
do i want to send this character into
the scene how does he
start and what is his intention his
objective at the beginning
am i caring about this person do i hate
this person do i love it like do i want
them to get
together with that guy at the end or do
i want them to not
how are they going to get from a to b
what do they want
and what are we anticipating is going to
get in their way if you have a
main issue about a character wanting
something and there's obstacles
you have to know who that character is
you have to connect with them
emotionally
you have to know what the obstacles are
yep and then
once you know those things preferably
what's at stake
then the questions would raise the
tension is out there figuring out what
the stakes are the stakes are going to
be the why
why am i here why do i care what's
what's going on what are they going to
win
what are they going to lose because if
not then why do i care if they reach the
goal
if they don't if there's nothing at
stake for them then i am going to be
that
much less invested why is this personal
for the main character
if the stakes aren't there if it if
the story if the hero succeeds or
doesn't succeed or whatever
why does it matter if it doesn't matter
i don't care
why are any of these characters doing
this or like why do we care about them
you know like what are the emotional
journeys like of the characters what's
the emotional journey
of this story as well not just the plot
how do we
elevate the emotion so that we feel this
more how you feel how you felt in that
moment
where you were you know let me feel that
too
don't be stingy what really hurts and
what really
and where my courage has to come from
and
in turn where this character's courage
and her truth has to come from why are
you telling the president not the past
you know
and so something just as emotional needs
to occur in your present in the film it
needs to happen to this character that
pain needs to happen to this character
how do you achieve that you know how to
achieve a trauma of a past
to affect the president was the
character after that loss
still going to be able to get what they
wanted once i know what a character
wants the next question is why
and you better have a good answer to why
a character wants what they want
why do they react a certain way you know
which creates the plot
it's all comes to character it's all
psychology how well do you know the
protagonist how well do you even know
your own characters
i think the biggest why
ironically is the setting up
of the why why the character wants what
they want
when this happened in the script why did
the character do it and
why do you find that so compelling and
when the character did this
why somebody is doing what they're doing
so their motivations become huge
that we understand their motivations
what's going on inside that character
that causes him or her to do those
things but the why
in terms of writing connects to the
reason
why characters do what they do
that's what audiences really want to
know and that comes to motivation so
motivation is really important i mean
it's it's the cliche actors question
right like what's my motivation why do i
why am i doing this why am i saying this
in a scene if i don't ever understand
why a character makes a choice on the
screen
then yeah i disengage how well do you
know what she was really thinking really
feeling really wanting really desiring
really expecting really
fearing at that time do i know can i
feel can i
sense do i have any idea of what's
really going on inside these characters
what the character
wants to truly believe about himself
but nothing in the world is saying this
is such who that woman
or man is and what they're like
and what their world looks like who they
are or what their
you know how you would describe that
character and what their journey is
going to be
if me and this character went out to get
a drink at a bar or something
what would we talk about how would the
conversation flow would he be doing the
talking would i be doing the talking
you know would it be balanced not
balanced would they leave after five
minutes because they have something to
do
i always try to think of like the
broader world of character and habits
outside of just the script how am i
feeling about these
people about these characters who they
are physically emotionally
socially you got to figure out what
their vulnerabilities are what their
flaws are
what they're good at what they're not
good at what their insecurities are
because we're all motivated by that
we're motivated by our insecurities
what really is a struggle what there's
the external stuff but you also have to
give them the internal stuff
uh you know what what are the
insecurities what are the demons what
you know all these things
what is the hero's wound what are they
afraid of how vulnerable you were
how stupid you were how arrogant you
were
which means how human you were at that
time can you do that one of the most
fundamental
things to understanding who the
character is
is that one single thing the flaw with
their flaw
how does your protagonist experience
temptation what's the big core wound in
your hero
what if he were actually human and not
all polished and perfect what is their
kind of quick takeaways from a quick
appearance versus like the deep down
stuff that they don't let out what is
the flaw in them
that is actually making their problem
worse how are they their own worst enemy
you know what is in them that's
vilifying their you know internal self
you know how do they have to overcome
their own uh
you know mind to accomplish what they're
setting out to do what the flaws to the
character are
before we start recognizing what this
inner conflict is or what this identity
is
or what dark places they might go what
is the negative
narrative that has come
from that wound and how is that getting
in the way
of the central character achieving the
goal and then
how through the pursuit
is the central character one step toward
healing that wound
what is that personal problem inside
that is hurting the hero
in such a fundamental way that it's
ruining their life
what is the question
that torments the hero
forever that will never be resolved
what's the unsolvable dilemma for
the hero that will never ever be solved
what is the fear that is crippling
in some way the character at the
beginning of the story and how do they
find the courage to overcome that
what is the character's central flaw and
then what is the strength that in the
end in a comedy they either
learn the opposite of or in a tragedy
was the strength that they failed to
learn the opposite of
imagine your protagonist transformed at
the end of the story
how is your protagonist relating
differently to other characters
at the end of the story how are they
relating differently than they were at
the beginning
and what do they understand at the end
of the story that they didn't understand
at the beginning if you want
the audience to have an eventual
cathartic
experience in your story that you need
to have that character be
good be appropriate be consistent and be
universal right so what does that mean
what is the message what is this the
thing that they are changing too what is
the experience like for this person
going through this what are they feeling
what are they
thinking how is this causing them to
change or re-prioritize
what what's in their life how they're
going to grow and change
what their thrust is going to be in the
story
what happens when the character figures
it out this moment of recognition
oh my god the effect that these events
are having on them
that will help you get in touch with
what the meaning of the story is
who's the antagonist what's their goal
and their flaw is he going to break
down the villain why are they your
antagonist
why your villain is right and why your
hero is wrong
what is heroic behavior what is
dastardly behavior
not thinking who's the good guy who's
the bad guy
who's the you know who's the one i'm
rooting for
uh in the end it's just let's get to
know them let's see who they are
a good villain is you understand why
they're doing what they're doing and you
understand
what they want just as much as you
understand what the protagonist wants
how can i make it more difficult for
them first of all but also
instead of having them announce their
feelings or desires
can they do it without saying anything
or if they
in a conversation how can they hide
their true desires
or feelings and cover it up with more
surface superficial subtextual language
so where there's dialogue there's
subtext
and where there's action there's
intention what are the characters
intentions behind their actions
subtextually what is going on between
these characters what's really going
now there's a private objective what am
i really doing what's
really driving me is it my control over
her or my
or my dominance of it you know what what
what is the really deeper objective am i
trying to prove her
to her that i'm a good leader i don't
know whatever it is how do you write
natural dialogue how do you
how do you write the way people really
speak what do they say
listen to what there was what people
were saying and how they were saying it
and
what inflections am i keeping that
rhythm
is that cadence still flowing when you
go to say something there's probably a
hundred different ways you could think
of to say it
why are you choosing the particular way
you you choose
and why your character is choosing to
say something that way and what they
really don't want to reveal like why
why will they go to this length but they
won't go just a little bit more
vulnerable
what is the character hiding from the
other person
consciously what is she hiding from him
and what is she hiding
from herself what's the thing that she's
not yet aware of that is really
driving her to know what they want to
conceal and what they want to
to give what does the main character
know and what does the main character
not know
here's my character now set them free
what are they going to do once they're
out in the world
they're if they're doing this and
they're in this kind of job or in this
kind of situation
then they most likely came from this
kind of background
that would bring them into this world
how
and then you sort of reverse engineer it
and then go back
so you just have to understand first off
what a story world
is what's the world of your show what's
something that surprises you
about this world how much of a world
is explored can you take your main
character
your protagonist your hero can you take
them out
of the story world and have your story
bro still be interesting can you take
the story out of the story world and
still have it be interesting
how do we make a world a sci-fi world
that
doesn't exist yet then how do we how do
we create it how to
build a world which is a super
hard and fascinating thing to do if
there's this technology that we create
like how does that affect
the world what's the commentary that
they're trying to put into
any individual story do you have a theme
that matters what do you want to say
about
the world what am i trying to say with
my movie what am i trying to say with my
book what i'm
trying to say with my video game and
what's a world that needs to hear that
message
how does politics work how does religion
work how
are people how does this technology
affect them
a lot of people focus on high concept
when it comes to story
and not and not people don't focus on
how to create a high concept for the
world itself
well do we want to make a heightened
version of that do we want to you know
stick straight to
the historical accuracy can i make a
storyboard log line out of it that's
independently interesting
and by adding in irony and a high
concept to the world itself
now you have some commerciality and some
interest
and something that is uh that that by
itself
can grab people's attention it's what
happens next what happens next what
happens next what's the conflict in the
scene what does my character want
in this scene what the scene is about
what's the conflict what do they want
what how is it serving the story who are
the people that populate
that scene what does each character want
do i know what
each character wants do i know what the
obstacles are do i know what's in the
way of him
or her achieving what they want in the
scene do they achieve what they want in
the city do they think they have
achieved it and maybe they haven't
have they achieved it and maybe they
don't realize they have well what are
the scenes
that express that excitement you know
that really really show
those beats that are that you have to
show on screen
how you keep that interesting how you
move from one scene to the next
what does this scene cause to happen
and how is that how is it the effect of
what happened before it
you've kind of looked at the scene in
terms of
of tracking what the character is going
to go through
throughout the entire script where does
where does the scene
fit into it how is it setting up for
other things what does it need to do
and does the scene serve that if not do
i need it can i change it
can i toss it does this mean we need
another scene where do they want to be
or what do they want to have happen to
the end of the scene
looking at the scenes like they're
little movies right like what is it
setting up for me
what's the goal of this scene and then
how does it resolve to get me to the
next thing
where structurally does the scene occur
do you have enough scenes
where the audience can relate and are
they going on an emotional journey an
interior journey
an external journey whatever the
combination of both
what are they going to do to try and do
that and then you go into the second act
where there are
where you have to look at the conflicts
is there enough is
is what he the steps he is doing are
they escalating in a way that at the
same time is
believable but also doesn't need too
much
patience what's gone really bad for
everybody like why is this the end of
the second act how can you
ramp up the tension how is it then going
to affect the rest of the story
what is the purpose of a story why do
people resonate with certain stories
what is it meant to do the last frame
comes up and it finishes what i want the
audience to feel
at that point what is it that they're
trying to accomplish in the story
and why should we care why should the
audience be
at the edge on the edge of their seat
right now what are they wondering about
what do they want to find out why do
they care what do they identify with
if i'm sitting watching this movie am i
am i moved forward at every single
moment am i learning something new am i
sucked into this world
whether the first act break came at page
30 or 70 whatever it may be
where are they excited when we go see
this movie what are we in for
everything the audience needs to know or
experience
to understand what's happening why it's
happening
and why they should care who's the
audience for this who's your audience
who my audience is how is the audience
going to tie
into the story emotionally does it grab
me and does it keep me
do i think this is going to strike a
chord with people first thing i'm
looking at is it does it grab me
do i care uh is it a story that
can i feel emotional about compelled by
you know if it's a
scary movie am i scared if it's a comedy
have i laughed
if it's emotional have i you know gotten
a lump in my throat
how is it that something i'm seeing from
people i don't know
is making me cry how do i relate that to
the audience
the audience is constantly wondering why
did that happen or where is this taking
us and
and as soon as you and you have to you
can't ask a question and then answer it
at the end
you have to ask a little question you
have to answer it
in the next scene or the next chapter or
whatever it is but then you have to pose
another question and so really
um a powerful story is one that
continues to ask questions
and deliver meaningful answers and
and satisfactory answers at this moment
in the script
what are the question marks that i as an
audience
am burning to have answered that made me
turn the page why am i interested
in continuing this what story are they
watching
what's happening why is it happening why
is it interesting or not interesting
who are the characters what are how are
they experiencing the characters how
would they describe the characters
are they engaged with the characters are
they not engaged with the characters
what does the audience know what does
the audience not know
wow what's going to happen to him oh
this is an interesting oh i
wasn't expecting that the movie ends and
you're you're trying to peace out
in your mind where this character went
and what they did and you're still
thinking about
the decisions they made then that's
that's a successful film
because it makes you feel like that
world was real and you cared about those
characters you found them interesting
enough to
contemplate why does it matter that they
solve this problem
why does the audience care whether they
solve it or not is it big enough and is
it relatable enough
what do i want the audience to feel when
they leave the cinema what happens to
that audience
the moment the movie's over and what
they're taking out of the
not what they've experienced during just
the two hours but what they take out of
there
the question for the writer is not what
you're going to say to the audience in
your movie but
what the audience is going to say to
themselves after this movie
how do you want the listener to receive
the story
what do you want the listener to get
from the story
how do you want the listener to see you
as the storyteller or even to see you as
the person
in the story what did i get from that
what is any residual
benefit to me for my life did i get from
that
what do you want them to be thinking
about worried about
fantasizing talking about discussing
with each other
how are you going to let the audience
know
that strangers who don't know what
you're going for
when they read your script do they
experience a story you experience
do they experience the characters you
experience what works and what doesn't
work which character is not
uh needed can i take two characters and
combine them
what moments that allow for creativity
are really worth it and what were just
sort of experiments even in process
why it wasn't working why it wasn't
resonating with people where
people are not experiencing what you're
intending
and why why why is it falling apart
is this any good or is this like really
terrible and if it is really terrible
can i salvage it
you know is there a way to make it
better how can i say this better
how can it sound more real how can it
sound more authentic
what's missing what's not being
communicated is this your intention here
what's not there will tell me
what's missing that's it this works but
how can we make this better how can we
go deeper how can it be more meaningful
that doesn't work what about
what are the things that aren't working
for people and then i'll figure out why
and i'll figure out how to solve them
where is the screenplay slow
does the plot have drive i'm just
focusing on the plot are there any big
holes is this does the piping go
together does it flow
does it have a natural flow does it make
me want to turn the pages
is the story interesting enough usually
for my horror stuff it's like
is there enough is there enough stuff in
here to care about the characters
but am i also coming up with enough
scares that we haven't seen before
what is working and what is not how does
the story work
like what would be a cool and then oh
okay
how do i get there oh my god what a
great expression what does that mean i'm
gonna take that if you ask the questions
that are the just the normal ones you
get the normal answers if you start
asking weird questions
you start getting you know the the
answers you didn't even know existed
so you know it's like you have to be
creative when doing research what's
going to happen when they find out
the truth whatever you made happen
something has to happen next and it's
what happens next what happens next what
happens next what happens next
i personally want to know what happens
next well what's going to happen next
i don't know i can't wait to find out
either and then what if
this happens and you're just like oh my
god
what if what if and then they thought of
it and they thought
why not let's try that what was your
process how did you get to an answer
what was that answer
what is this about what what are you
trying to say what's the overall theme
of this what are we exploring here
and get everybody all the way back to
that ground level idea
what these quote rules are that actually
make for a great story
and these so-called conventional rules
that are not true certainly not true now
and they probably never were
what it is that i am about what's my
what's my mission or what's important
here what are the important
things what are the essential things
that you want to convey
what is most important to you both
in your life like what do you want to do
but i think also
in your writing what story really should
be
in people and in society how do we
nourish people's minds and hearts
am i actually creating something that's
making the world a better place
am i actually sending out a message that
i would want people to take to heart
if art and film and writing isn't the
place then where is the place to do that
i want you to become them
by falling into darkness backward
can you do that you come up with
something like that and you go oh
you know an audience will be like what
it does take courage and to make a good
movie
takes even more courage you have to take
a chance you have to go out on a limb
you have to do something that hasn't
been tried before because if we've seen
it all before why do we want to see it
again
you